The Washington Post is signaling there
may be more revelations about what CBS
News knew about claims of inappropriate
conduct by former anchor Charlie Rose in
a story published yesterday the post
detailed three occasions during which it
says CBS managers were warned of roses
conduct the newspaper spoke to 27 women
who claimed Rose sexually harassed them
including 14 here at CBS one of the post
reporters then tweeted it's not over yet
and a Warner is following this story and
a good morning mid-morning CBS News says
it cannot corroborate or confirm many of
the situations described in the Post
report the company has said it never
received complaints of sexual harassment
by rose before his firing last November
but roses conduct allegedly spanned
decades his behavior in some ways
remained remarkably consistent over the
years as to how he would act toward
women in the workplace Washington Post
reporter Amy Britten says her team spoke
with 107 current and former CBS News
employees many of whom allege a pattern
of inappropriate behavior by Charlie
Rose
it was repeatedly groping lewd sexual
remarks calling women late at night
asking them personal questions about
their sex lives the paper reports CBS
management was told about Rose's conduct
on three different occasions dating back
to 1986 when he made lewd comments to a
staffer on the CBS Morning News welcome
to the debut of CBS this morning in the
days leading up to the 2012 launch of
CBS this morning an employee told then
executive producer Chris Licht that Rose
forcibly kissed her CBS says Lynch spoke
with rose and abided by the accusers
request not to tell Human Resources
a CBS spokesperson says that was within
the scope of CBS policy at the time
Licht moved on to lead the Late Show
with Stephen Colbert as Ryan Cade Roe
assumed the role of executive producer
for CBS this morning The Post reports
Cade Roe's former assistant warned him
last year that Rose was treating another
employee to what she considered unusual
lunches at expensive restaurants while
Rose floated other job opportunities to
her a court
to a CBS spokesperson Cade Rowe
determined it was for a job interview he
says his former assistant did not tell
him about inappropriate behavior there
was not knowledge of these events CBS
News President David Rhodes has insisted
the network never protected Charlie
Rhodes in a note to employees he
revealed the company has retained an
outside law firm to help investigate
sexual harassment and misconduct
complaints Britten says her inbox is
filling with potential new leads we're
looking at the information that is
coming in and we're vetting it and we're
continuing our reporting Charlie Rose
has not responded to a CBS News request
for comment but told the post your story
is unfair and inaccurate through an
attorney three women also told the Post
they plan to file a lawsuit in the
coming days gale all right Anna thank
you listen the more you hear about the
story the more awkward and more
uncomfortable it is but the good news is
if you can say good news is that the
company's investigating hired somebody
from the outside and I really do feel
let the chips fall where they may this
investigation is continuing and we take
it very very seriously as the son of
somebody worked in the news business in
the 50s and 60s I think about the women
who had to come forward what they had to
the anguish they had to live through the
courage it took to come forward and the
frustration of having to be silent and
feel like you can't have a voice so it's
good that they can get some kind of way
through this investigation I also kind
of I also think about the other damage
in this which is all the people who work
here those long nights fling themselves
across the country cover stories who are
a part of this now and and and dealing
with it as well which is why it's
important we're investigating the past
but even more important that we're
moving forward yeah and that there are a
lot of professionals in the building
doing a very good job I don't want
people to forget you know there are a
lot of people doing a lot of good work
here's you point it out well said